[Müzik]
Merhaba
değerli hanımefendiler ve beyefendiler
Merhaba ben Erdoğan Turan
hoş geldiniz
1965 Köln Almanya doğumluyum
iki evlat sahibiyim 28 yıldır evliyim 39
yıldır da otelciyim Erkan bey Turizm
bilgileri ben kendimi ne yazık ki ne
yazık ki yanlış anlaşılır özür dilerim
Ben kendimi Turizmci olarak değil Otelci
olarak tanımıyorum Çünkü ben safkan
otelciyim
teşekkürler
sizlere en büyük zenginliğimiz olan ve
hazinemiz olan ulu önder Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk gibi hitap etmek istedim
hanımefendiler ve beyefendiler olarak
[Alkış]
Hanımefendi ve Beyefendi kelimesinin
Efendi takısı kendi kendini yönetebilen
eğitim ve gelişimine önem veren birey
sıfatını ifade etmektedir
Siz de buraya kişisel gelişiminizi bir
parçasını tamamlamak üzere
geldiğinize göre efendilik takısını Tam
da Size uygun olan bir sıfat olduğunu
düşünüyorum iyi yaşayın
öncelikle kendine yönetebilen özgür
birey olmak kendini Efendisi olmak en
büyük hazine olduğunu düşünüyorum Bizler
bu topraklarda çok büyük bedeller
ödeyerek efendilik statüsüne erişebildik
bunu hiç unutmayalım Değerli misafirler
hazine
Turizm üzerine hazineden de
otelcilikle genel anlamda Ben Turizmci
olarak
Otelci olarak hazinenin mesleki'den
ziyade benim için alınan ifadesini
sizlerle Aslında paylaşmak istiyorum
kişisel bakış açımla alakalı Türk dil
kurumuna göre baktığınızda da hazine
genel manada altın gümüş mücevher gibi
bazı malzemelerin anlamına geliyor ve
bunları bunun gibi değerli eşyaları
sakladığınız yer gibi algılanabiliyor
fakat insan hayatında gerçek hazine
maddi varlıkların çok daha ötesinde
olduğunu düşünüyorum
varlığımızın deneyimlerimizin
ilişkilerimizi şekillendiren soyut
zenginlikler de insan hayatındaki en
büyük hazinedir insanoğlu belli bir
zaman dilimi içerisinde Bu yerkürelere
pek çok role giriyor
önce doğuyoruz çocuk oluyoruz genç
oluyoruz sevgili oluyoruz evlat olur
anne baba oluyoruz yönetici oluyoruz
oluyoruz da oluyoruz bunun sonu yok ama
bu rollerin hepsi başında sağlık olmazsa
bütün bu işler ve görevler anlamını
kaybediyor
geçtiğimiz yıllarda
2019'un sonu 2020'de tüm dünyada
yaşadığımız komik ve pandemi sebebiyle
de
ister istemez sağlığın ne kadar önemli
olduğunu zaten biliyorduk da fakat
bilincinde olmadığımız anlar olmuştu
daha da ön plana çıktı ve değer kazandı
fiziksel duygusal zihinsel halimiz
tatmin edici bir yaşam sürmemizi
sağlayan paha biçilmez bir varlıktır
zevklerin tadını çıkarmak sevdiğimiz
etkinliklere katılmak ve sevdiğimiz
değer verdiğimiz insanlarla canlılara
bakabilmek ancak sağlıklı olmakla
mümkündür sağlık zenginliktir deyimi
asla ve alınmaması gereken bir ifadedir
bence
sizlere tavsiyem size sunulmuş olan bu
armağana sahip çıkmayı çok küçük yaşta
alışkanlık haline getirip
öğrenmenizi öğretmenizi diliyorum Bu
Bence en büyük başarımız olacaktır
birazcık da affınıza sığınıyorum
heyecanlıyım İlk dedim
Erhan bey gibi kaç 400 müydü
o kadar tecrübeli dediğim birçok sahneye
çıktığımız zamanlar oluyor sahnede
misafirlere üç dilde dört dilde
konuşuyoruz ama burası farklı hakikatten
farklı farklı
dilim damağım bile kurudu yani sizlerin
karşısında şey yapmak için Sağ olun
teşekkürler
Çok teşekkürler
Bir de listede gördüğünüz heralde o 11
kişinin biri bir tanesi benim ve ilki
benim
Arkadan gelen üstatlar
konuşmacı
o kadar profesyonelce o kadar rahatlıkla
buraya çıkıp da benim gibi okumadan veya
kopya çekmeden konuşanlar çok ki onların
altında da ezilmek de istemiyorum ama
affınıza söylüyorum Sağ olun
[Alkış]
insan hayatındaki diğer en büyük
hazinemiz bana göre zamanımız zaman çok
değerli
zamanı yenilenemek veya geri almaya
sınırlı bir kaynaktır alınamayan bir
sınırlı kaynaktır
Bu biraz önemli okumam gerekiyor ömrünüz
hücrelerin içinde bulunan
telomerlerinizin uzunluğu kadarmış
diyorum Çünkü bu tıpta veya
biyolojide var olan bir şey eşim
yardımcı oldu da o da buradan sufle
yapıyor
O yüzden akıllıca ve amaçlı bir şekilde
yapmamız gereken bir Değerdir hazinedir
Anılar yaratmanıza tutkularınızın
peşinden gitmenize hedefinize ulaşmanıza
olanak tarayacaktır
sizleri büyüme gelişme öğrenme fırsatı
veriyor elinizden Elinizde
tutabildiğiniz her an bir hazinedir ve
zamanınızın nasıl geçireceğinizi
hayatınızın zenginliğidir ilişkiler
hazinesi ve insan için paha biçilmezdir
burada İlişki derken Tabii ki genel
kavramda bir ilişki Biraz önce
söylediğim gibi 28 yıldır evliyim Evet
29'a gireceğiz Ben eşimle tanıştığımda
ruh ikizimi bulduğumu düşündüm
ve en büyük hazine hayatına girdi
ikizi diyorum Aynı zamanda Burcu da
ikizler burcu
hayatım hep
çok kalabalık Evet doğru
O yüzden
ilişkide şansa bağlı ama hakikaten çok
önemli olduğunu düşünüyorum
evlendiğiniz kişi
arkadaşınız yani ailenizi seçemiyorsunuz
ama ilişkiye girdiğiniz kişileri
ilişkiyi yarattığınız ve sürdüreceğiniz
kişiler çok önemli bu size bağlı bir şey
o yüzden
şanslıysanız doğru ilişki kurduğunuz
takdirde de güzel bir hazine elde
ettiğinizi düşünüyorum ve bunu da
korumakla mükellefsiniz diye düşünüyorum
insanlarla olan bağlantınızın hayatınızı
anlam ve mutluluk getirir aileniz
arkadaşlarınız Sevdikleriniz olan
ilişkileriniz bizim genel moral ve
motivasyonumuzda ve aidiyet duygumuzu da
geliştirmektedir
başkalarıyla kurduğumuz Bağlar Anılar
yaratır
Bu da kişisel gelişiminizi
destekliyordur Bu ilişkiler sırasında
hatalarımızın doğal olarak olacaktır şu
anda benim olduğu gibi okumakta zor
bacanlanıyorum bu hatalar da bizim
gelişimimizi sağlayan deneyimlerimiz
olacaktır Benim için de Ayriyeten bir
deneyim oluyor zaten Ailede başlayan
ilişkilerimiz bizim en büyük
hazinemizdir bunun üstüne eklediğimiz
diğer ilişkilerimiz sizin gelecekteki
dünyanızı oluşturacaktır
ilişkileriniz Ne kadar sağlam ve zengin
ise
hazinenizde o kadar büyük olacaktır
your Network içiyor Next Word
deyimi de tam bu konumda açılımıdır yani
cebindeki para mal mülk varlığınız değil
tanıdığınız veya sizi seven kişilerin
niteliği Asil hazineniz asıl hazineniz
değerleriniz ve zenginliğinizdir
Tabii ki burada
samimiyetinizin ve dürüstünüzün
ilişkilerdeki devamlılığı ilişkilerin
kalitesini de etkileyecektir çıkar
amaçlı olmamalı
kişisel farkındalık ve kişisel gelişim
sizi siz yapan en büyük hazinedir
kişisel gelişim için çaba gösterme
yetisi ömür boyu sürecek bir yolculuktur
kişisel farkındalık güçlü yönlerinizi
zayıf yönlerinizi önem sıralarınızın
değerlerinizi zamanında fark ederek
yapacağınız seçimlerdeki doğru
kararlarınızı almanızı sağlayacaktır
merhamet ve nezaket insan ruhunu
zenginleştiren bambaşka bir hazine
empati kurma empati gösterme yeteneğini
tüm dünyada olumlu bir dalgalanma etkisi
yaratır
merhamet ve nezaket çift taraflı
olduğu takdirde mutluluk ve tatmin
getirir bu tip Erdemler daha şefkatli ve
uyumlu bir topluma teşvik ederek güçlü
bir topluluk duygusu yaratır
son olarak anlam ve amaç arayışı
yaşamınıza Güven tatmin sağlayan bir
hazinedir aslında uzun ve mutlu
yaşamanın Sırrı
hayatınızın amacını bulmaktır Hz
Mevlana'nın da dediği gibi; gayesi
olmayanın varlığından şüphe ederim
imiz hobilerimiz sosyal
sorumluluklarımız üstlendiğimiz veya
üstlenmek zorunda kaldıklarımız
faaliyetlerimiz hayatımıza anlam ve
tatmin duygusunu oluşturur bizlere biz
bunun Biz dışında Biz dışında bir anlam
katar
bütün hizmeti bütüne hizmet etmeye karşı
açacağını zorluklar sizi daha güçlü
kılacaktır Peki nasıl bulacağız bu
hayatımızın anlam ve amacını yaparken
mutlu olduğunuzu kendinizi yetenekli ve
önde hissettiğinizi şu anda çok o planda
değilim gerçi ama Yine de mutluyum
adamlar yönünüzü bulmanız için kılavuz
olacaktır bunu belirledikten sonra bu
alanda ilerlerken Arada
kazanabiliyorsanız onu keşfetmişsiniz
demektir diye düşünüyorum
en son olarak dünyanın ve toplumun Neye
ihtiyacınız olduğunu amacını Entegre
edersiniz Hayat amaçlarınızdan birisini
bulmuş olursunuz ama sadece birisini
Tabii ki tüm bu hazineleri beslemek sizi
çoğaltacak ve parlatacaktır
derim yaşam yolculuğunuz boyunca
İçinizde ve çevrenizde bulunan gerçek
hazineleri bulmanız ve tanımanız
dileğiyle
teşekkürler
herhalde biraz hızlı okudum resmi okuma
şeyi bitti İzin verirseniz daha 18 buçuk
dakika vaktim var benim de
biraz Fontaine geçeyim isterseniz benim
için bunu okumak önemlidir neden çünkü
bana verilen
bu şanstan ve bu fırsattan dolayı ve
TEMA'nın hazine oluşundan dolayı düzgün
bir şeyler üstatlardan önce de çıkınca
doğru ifadeleri kullanmak istedim biraz
oturup
tez yazar gibi yazmaya başladık Ama
biraz fazla şey olduysa sizler için
teorik olduysa özür dilerim
biraz belki kendinden bahsedeyim
Biraz önce söylediğim gibi 1965 Almanya
doğumluyum Almanya'da doğdum büyüdüm
kısa Türkiye'ye geliş gidişlerim oldu
hasbelkader 1984 yılında bu meslekle
tanıştım
teşviki mesaiye başladık 2 ay sonra ben
dedim bu işi yapmam Ya ne olacak Biz Ben
böyle ne uğraşacağım diye başladığımda
Rahmetli olan bir Metro otelin vardı
İtalyan Dino Allah rahmet eylesin
İtalyan ama Sonuçta o da Allah'a
inanıyor
bir tane evladı vardı
Ben 8 evladıydım Benim mesleki oğlu
olarak severdi Benim de aslında mesleki
babamdır bu meslekte kalmamı ilerlememi
sağlayan kişiydi ve ben öğrencisiydim 3
yıllık eğitimden sonra diplomamı aldım
başka yerlere gittim geldim Askerliğimi
bedelli yaptım Tekrar döndüğümde tekrar
o otele yaptım ve beni tanıştırırken ben
o zaman müdür olarak gittim onun üstüne
müdür olarak gitmiştim yönetici asistan
olarak
gururla hep şey yapardı omuzuma eline
atardı ve misafirlerle konuşurken benim
öğrencimdi şimdi benim Müdürüm oldu
derdi ama bunu söylerken de öyle bir
gururla öyle bir samimiyetle söylerdi ki
çok mutlu olurdum ve gurur duyurdum
Ben de elimden geldiğince bunca yılın
içerisinde birçok yerde çalıştım Yurtiçi
yurt dışı İngiltere Mısır Almanya
Avusturya Türkiye Bodrum Antalya Finike
birçok bölgede çalıştım ve birçok takım
arkadaşlarım oldu Onlarla beraber 16
tane inşaattan Otel açtık burada
inşaat açılımları yeni açılışlar
aramızdaki turizmciler otelciler
bilirler benim için bir bebek gibi yani
çocuğun gibi görüyorsun hala ben açılışı
yaptım Bizim otel diye konuşuyorum
Halbuki otelden Ayrılalı 10 yıl olmuş 15
yıl olmuş
fakat bebek gibidir onun büyüdüğünü
görürsün başarıları senin mutlu eder ve
orada da çalıştığın alt kadrolarda olan
arkadaşlar bugün belli pozisyonlarda
departman müdürü olmuş genel müdür olmuş
Koordinatör olmuş siyah olmuş veya bu
meslekten kaçmış
Neden Çünkü bu meslek para ile yapılacak
bir iş değil
severek yapmadığınız takdirde ki Her
meslek için her iş için aynı şey geçerli
ama bu aşkla yapılması gereken Gönül
bağıyla yapılması gereken ve İnançla
yapılması gereken bir şey bütün bu
saydıklarım Tabii ki ilişkiler içinde
geçerli ve ben de eşim de burada olduğu
için ona da tekrar burada kendisini
sevdiğimi belirtmek istiyorum ve bana
vermiş olduğu destekten dolayı Alkışla
rica ediyorum
son bir cümle Daha sizlerle paylaşmak
istiyorum Benim hayatımda
34-35 yıl önce tanıştığım bir yazar
filozof
Amerikalı O da rahmetli diyelim tank
gibi belki duymuşsunuzdur onun birkaç
kitabını okumuştum bir sözü Benim için
hayat felsefesini veya hamak Hayat
amacını simgeleyen tek bir cümledir ve
bunu da genelde herkesle paylaşmak
istiyorum
Onunla da sözümü bitirmek istiyorum
sende yakmak istediğim ateşin gözü bende
yanmalı Bu sözü dinleyip hazmedeniz ne
kadar derin bir şey olduğunu Ve her şey
için kullanabileceğinizi
anlayacaksınızdır beni dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür ediyorum Sağ olun teşekkürler
[Müzik]